loved his work for years you have and
stepbrothers party down which is
fantastic I miss that show Parks and Rec
and is so much more including now season
two a big little lies which premiered a
couple Sundays ago on HBO at 9:00
Eastern Time and Pacifica to see you
Adam Scott how are you sir
wait what's going on in your life it's
happening everything good everything's
good summertime the other kids our kids
to summer activities together yes as a
matter of fact I think my oldest son and
your youngest daughter are already a
baking situation right now it's a
cupcake camp right I never had one of
those one of those you know what I mean
me neither I was given a stick and a
flashlight with no batteries it's old I
have a great summer and sit around a
campfire and tell stories that freak you
out and keep you up all night
I do that there might have been a kiln
of some sort a kiln my dad told such
scary stories on camping trips are you
serious oh my god he was great at the
mat the man with the Golden Arm okay
does anyone else know this that's a
Sinatra movie isn't it isn't that an old
the man with the Golden Arm or some well
the golden guy okay so no I don't know
this story if you'd care to regale go
for because it would take a long time
and it everyone gets scared no kidding I
don't want I don't want anyone okay it's
a little dark over there so do you think
anybody right now with your daughter and
my son around like some fondant party
stories right now what do you think I
think yes the opposite is happening so
when it's telling an incredibly happy
story and they're having a grand old
time
oh my gosh now your oldest son has
started falling head over heels in love
with the national football league from
what you're telling me correct he's he's
incredible
flag football player really incredible
football player yes like like what is
running back okay safety sometimes okay
he is great he's just started a couple
years ago and just
worked his way up and now he is so fast
he's his superglue on his hands he's
great he's a great football player and
he's gotten really into and through him
I've fallen in love with football for
the first time I was always kind of on
the periphery sure but what a game and I
know I'm talking to a group of people
who know this breaking this terrific
game guys well done I'm gonna pass that
off the chain of command will you yeah I
don't know if they're aware just how
good that game is they need some
reassurance well what are you what are
you fallen in love with mostly then with
your son's passion for the sport well I
love throwing the football with him that
never gets old for me really I'm sure
for him he may get old throwing the
football with his dad but love it but
also the game itself is it's just so fun
to watch once you get the kind of wide
angle of what's going on just trying to
be a guy and how you can use you know
every game of inches it is a fascinating
game with endless strategic possums yes
that's a neck up game it's not just a
physical no Adam Scott no it is a mental
game on many many ways it's almost it's
I love how you're falling in love with
the chess portion of yes so his team is
the he was on 49ers for flight football
but 49ers are also his favorite team he
is a 49ers diehard fan now as the 49ers
no I wouldn't be telling too many tales
out of school normally a kid likes a
front runner yeah how old is your son
he's 12 okay so normally a 12 year old
will be okay I love the Patriots I love
and even here in the ranch yes yeah
where did the 49ers come from Scott his
mother and I are both from the Bay Area
okay I grew up for in 49er fan family so
I think that and when he was like three
we were on an elevator with a few 49ers
when we were staying in a hotel and that
bear
he doesn't remember it but he remembers
the story of it so for whatever reason
forty-niners is in his blood george
Kittel is his guy pretty good it's a
good one very good and he also loves
that they're the underdog and that
there's someone to you know Garoppolo
was out for was it the entire and so I
think he you know an underdog story is
is fun and so he's always something to
root for hoping you know better okay
well I mean the 49ers I think they're
coming into town so you're gonna take
your son to games and stuff like yeah
and for sure look at you man yeah look
at you and all be equally as into it so
are you gonna have you done like the
show um YouTube videos of Montana and
young okay have you gone down that
rabbit hole we've watched there's so
many great documentaries of the heyday
sure that's what we grew up with was
Bill Walsh it's incredible I know and
how if the 49ers became a great team and
like the early 80s how it all kind of
turned out it's great story I mean this
is all new I love it it's great Adam
Scott here on the Rich Eisen show do you
want to chime in on the participation
trophy aspect of things since your kids
are here in the youth sports you want to
ask the poll question of Adam Scott yeah
Adam what's your what's your take on
participation trophies no harm keep them
they suck destroy them don't care you're
fun no harm keep them and I say that
only because if it weren't for
participation trophies I would have none
although once I did get the most
improved two trophies in Little League
which I knew was a bit of a slam at the
time you did not improve you don't know
if there's any tangible evidence on my
part okay so did but it was something I
walked home I can't went home with the
trophy what's the big deal yeah what do
you guys think I think it's not a
problem
until they turn like seven eight my son
well I mean Cooper's now eight he got a
plaque sure he got a plaque and but
they're all all the kids come running
back in and they're keeping score did we
win today did we lose today we're all
trying to tell them that score does you
know that doesn't matter yet
yeah it's like are you out or are you
safe that's what matters not like wins
and losses let's all try and have some
fun but after a while though when
they're 910 what do we start to age 9 so
it's 9 to 12 so that's about that's
about it yeah once you're past 12 cuz I
know my 12 year old now getting a
participation trophy would maybe not
yeah I don't know if that would have
compute from or I think it would compute
as this is just a thing whereas you know
once you hit 1213 I think you you want
to win and sure okay so everyone should
chime in right now it's what is it was
47% think they suck that's absurd I
think we just needed to put some sort of
age group there down there you know what
I mean next I think once you have kids
too that you might the calculation might
change yeah definitely it is for me I
always thought that they suck yeah right
but then you know look my five-year-old
is now duct-taped together with the with
a zip like a plaster bring that home
really I am definitely not bringing this
home okay no it's funny like my mom sent
a text during the commercial break two
words gorilla glue yeah she knows my mom
was the queen of arts and crafts moms
now that's right Adam Scott here on the
Rich Eisen show big little lies your
name was trending on Twitter are you
aware that over the weekend yeah I'm not
sure is entirely my because of me though
it was the golfer didn't yeah but he
wasn't involved
I think obviously the sunday of US Open
Golf might have yeah but he wasn't in
contention towards the end referee yeah
he was five back you were and you were
in more contention in the episode of big
little laws that I was around at the
same time of the airing show I don't I
honestly think it is it is the
popularity of the show and then your
scenes in them
on how you are occasionally put upon as
we just saw uh-huh and the the clip that
we just saw right that's right that's
right but I know he had a he kind of he
missed a putt yesterday or on Sunday am
I correct
you know what you you might know more
than me right Milken Rich Eisen show
researcher l0 is pointing that out right
there and I should know I played with
Adam Scott and his celebrity pro-am did
you months ago yeah I did it could've
been nicely yeah I've heard he's a great
guy we've never met but since I think
2004 was the first time we did a joint
interview where we had like a
side-by-side we answered the same
questions and some magazine are you
serious yeah so it's been when he was
just starting out and I was kind of just
starting out so it's been a while but
we've never met okay well then then
let's put a pin in talking about your
show and we'll return to that let's do
what we were planning on doing from
before since we brought up Adam Scott
the golfer and Adam Scott the the actor
right here on the Rich Eisen showing big
little eyes season 2 on HBO it started
already are you guys ready to play Mike
Dell to foe what we call Adam Scott or
Adam Scott please hit the drop get the
drop please
[Applause]
punch me in the face okay I'm gonna give
a round of applause that's a good sounds
like that sounded very lifelike
right there yeah like you'd really want
it to get hit in that manner that's
right but I think then I do get punched
in the face what I remember from that
scene okay here we go
you guys I'm gonna sit a fact and you
guys are gonna have to guess if it's
about Adams got the golfer or Adam Scott
who's here to my right he'll the answer
first up once invited Luke Skywalker
Mark Hamill to his second grade birthday
party is it the actor or golfer who goes
first you go my factor and yeah I agree
Adams got the actor and that is that was
me no kidding that was Ben did he show
he didn't show but many years later he
surprised me on Kimmel right yeah so I
got my wish sort of came true how did
you invite him how did that and I wrote
him a letter and gave it to my mom to
send and as far as I know she found some
address and sent it off and it's weird
like some the Skywalker Ranch or hands
of George Lucas I don't know in 1981
where would you be sending it because I
remember it was right when Empire
Strikes Back came out um and that was
and that was the theme of your party I
imagine how to be a star well Rob ibly
but I remember telling my friends like
so
Mark Hamill might come to the birthday
just so you know you're gonna wanna want
to make it because there's a chance that
he's getting your reaction when Kim will
surprise you with him was truly yeah
that was most that was a out-of-body
weird just being surprised on television
like that is something that it's an
unique feeling okay she sent the letter
to Tatooine I mean that's right look at
you I mean look at you with a Star Wars
reaction I mean we're doing this right
at that point all right
next up is it Adam Scott golfer Adam
Scott to my right previously dated
actress Kate Hudson and tennis stars
honor
Ivanova CH and
Maria Sharapova Wow Adam Scott the actor
I got to give you all the credit
congratulations Mike they'll to fo Adam
Scott the golfer Adam yeah you know I'm
flattered but you're a handsome man I
have been married since 2005 so I don't
think the math really works and that
doesn't work out right there what hey
Hudson perhaps I mean it is Los Angeles
but you never know yeah okay next up
graduated from UNLV is it Adam Scott -
my writer the golfer golfer Mike golfer
okay it is true of the gone yep
where'd you go to school the American
Academy of Dramatic Arts very different
than you and they did yeah terrific
world-renowned golf program
next up Billy big he's a big Billy Joel
fan and go-to karaoke song as scenes
from an Italian restaurant
[Music]
Adam Scott actor Mike Bell - for what I
like that's my go-to Billy Joel song is
that right yeah golfer okay and Adam
that's me is that the best song the best
song but it's long you mean to take the
karaoke everyone's patience which is
part of the fun because just when
someone's like thinks it's gonna be
their turn you're like no no this is a
whole new right we forget Ben Brenda and
Eddie's life goes on and Eddie didn't
last that long
what six we're the popular steady in the
summer 75 oh yeah hanging the Queen at
the prom
yeah yeah and then here we are waving
them goodbye right okay next one
he's an average surfer Oh golfer Mike
golfer boy copy me cuz you never surfed
next one rode the bench in Little League
and passed the time selling concessions
the golfer the actor with the
participation trophy yeah probably
Plus I think that just sounds like an
actor road what concessions did you sell
back in the day Adam I would I got so
bored on the bench I would just go
around the back of the dugout go to the
concession stand and sell concessions at
my own games the customers would be like
because I had my uniform on they're like
wait a second aren't you you guys
playing what's going on I'm like yeah
whatever I was more of a Bubble Yum you
know what I got the other day after coop
got his his end-of-season plaque not a
trophy they were handing out the big
league chew pass oh yeah have you had
when was the last time you tried big
league chew somewhat recently this is my
son jumps it whenever they're in yeah
right it's just there it is right such
an amazing rush like it's almost like
pop rocks
yeah that's Pepsi like which you know as
we all know Mike you allegedly winged
and sour at lost his life for Oh what
flavor did you get the other day rich oh
I got this the regular bubble regular
and I like grape it was great
literally for 30 seconds after that
you're just like oh my god I feel
horrible and it's just cud silly putty
is what it actually felt like and
resembled not like I actually chewed
that last one of Adam Scott or Adam
Scott once got kicked out of a wedding
along with Paul Rudd and all fur what
happened well this first of all I don't
think we've established that this was me
[Laughter]
sure okay guilty uh you know it was a
fun wedding we had a great time and and
unbeknownst to us there was a video that
we participated in for the for the groom
mm-hmm they we weren't aware was going
to be shown at the wedding reception he
thought it was a video to just be passed
along to the groom for the bachelor
party or for whatever just have fun and
so you know on the video we were just
not entirely appropriate it was a it was
it was a bummer so terrible who was who
informed you you had to leave who did
the ejecting well I I believe I believe
it was it was a friend of the groom's
was like I think you guys should
probably go oh
and we're like okay but it was also an
out-of-town wedding so we weren't Oh No
so we were just like I guess we'll just
go to the bar down the street and kind
of explore the town it was it was a we
felt terrible and went to the the brunch
the next day you know they have a brunch
the day after the water of course to
apologize and and felt like a-holes but
you know makes a decent story
did you ask when you reject it I'm
fascinated by the story did you ask when
you were ejected if brunch rules still
applied or did you justice you just
showed up at the brunch no we we called
to see if it would be appropriate if we
came to the moon so the ejection only
applied to the wedding yeah yeah and I
do remember the brunch the showing up to
the brunch was it wasn't a full-throated
yes please come to the brunch it was
like a half yes you should this would be
an opportunity to apologize so we're
like we gotta go we have apologized well
it kind of makes sense that that's the
response because brunch is neither here
nor there either
myself as a medium it's a middle ground
good thing anyway
you don't gets nothing that just
actually steaks it's no it doesn't
actually exist kind of makes sense it
that's the way it would be free of an
issue that no one saw the humor in your
video no there were some all right
before I let you go big little lies yeah
Meryl Streep has been added to the cast
yeah is she she the prankster on the set
now or what is what is that lot always
pulling pranks just taking people's
toothbrushes no toothbrushes what prank
is that I'm talking about you know the
toothbrush Frank why I asked a silly
question what is it like on the set with
her it's great she's really lovely and
and so incredible obviously yes and it's
it just it's I think everyone else in
the in the cast and crew were the entire
time were just like I can't believe
Meryl Streep is here right on the show
and and she just is amazing
well it's a testament to the cast that
of which you are part that she's like
yes I will be part of that in a
testament to the success of of year one
yes like you know I I'm up for joining
that yeah I mean that cast already is
unbelievable so part of Adam Scott yeah
yeah it's it's it's great I'm I'm really
happy to to be a part of it and and she
her character the the great thing about
Meryl Streep's character on the show is
that it's it's a really unique strange
character the the the role that she's
jumping into is is a really odd
dangerous figure on the show so it's a
lot of fun yeah and it's just a major
big-time hit on on HBO and it's just
started season number two
last week Reese Witherspoon Nicole
Kidman Shane shailene woodley Meryl
Streep zoe kravitz
at laura dern and of course you sir yeah
you sir i'ma level I left a few on the
cutting room floor right there
Congrats on all that Congrats oh thanks
buddy I think you know could come back
any time but I'll see you before that at
mr. Adam Scott on both Twitter and
Instagram for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app